imaginons qu'on a un pendule qui se
balancent autour d'un pivot
avec une masse m1 et une longueur
constante elle
donc le pendule peut se balancer le long
d'un cercle de rayon elle et on essaye
de déterminer son mouvement au cours du
temps
alors on va faire la proxima sion que la
masse n'ait subi ne subit que la force
de gravité son poids diriger vers le bas
avec l'intensité qui est donnée par
l'accélération de la pesanteur terrestre
donc en particulier on néglige les
frottements de la masse avec l'air
pour se repérer on va imaginer un axe
vertical
et on va repérer la position du pendule
au cours du temps par un angle teta qui
du coup peuvent varier au cours du temps
on va également imaginé deux vecteurs
qui forment une base
ces deux vecteurs perpendiculaire le
vecteur er qui est dirigé dans la
direction du pendule est le vecteur est
état qui lui est perpendiculaire qui est
dirigé dans la direction selon laquelle
augmente l'angleterre a donc il faut
faire bien attention ici ces deux
vecteurs donc ce sont deux vecteurs de
longueur un des vecteurs unités et ces
deux vecteurs peuvent varier au cours du
temps puisque si le pendule se trouve un
autre endroit à un autre instant les
deux vecteurs vont être orientées
différemment
maintenant qu'on a défini la situation
on peut commencer à écrire quelques
équations
tout d'abord le vecteur position de la
masse par rapport au pivot ce vecteur si
on le notera m c'est simplement la
longueur de la tige
x le vecteur er ce vecteur si
maintenant on peut également écrire la
vitesse du pendule le vecteur vitesse du
pendule donc c'est un vecteur qui est
dirigée suivant est et a uniquement
puisque le pendule se déplacent le long
d'un cercle
est la norme de la vitesse est donné par
la longueur en effet plus le pendule est
long plus la vitesse va être grande
lorsqu'il parcourt un certain angle
x la variation de l'angle au cours du
temps qu on notera tête à point donc le
point ici veut dire dérivés par rapport
au temps
et le tout dirigé suivant le vecteur
unités deux états
alors pour bien démontrer ça on peut
imaginer que le pendule parcours un
certain angle
delta teta en un certain temps delta tu
es
donc la longueur qu'il a parcouru ici
cette longueur est donnée par l x delta
teta puisque c'est la longueur d'un arc
de cercle de rayon elle et d'angles
delta teta et donc la vitesse qui est la
distance parcourue
/ le temps écoulé
et effectivement donné par l x delta
teta sur delta t c'est à dire la dérive
et de teta par rapport à tes lorsqu'on
passe à la limite
deux expressions qui vont également nous
être utile ce sont les dérivés de er et
2 e d'état par rapport au ton
donc on notera toujours avec un point
pour dire la dérive et par rapport au
temps là en effet on a vu que les
vecteurs er et 2 états peuvent tourner
au cours du temps puisqu'il tourne avec
le mouvement du pendule
est alors comment varie ces deux
vecteurs et bien tout d'abord le vecteur
er imaginons que le pendule se situe à
un certain angle puis tourner un autre
angle et bien le vecteur er aura tourné
donc si on reporte ce premier vecteur
ici on voit qu'il a tournée d'un angle
qui est donnée tout simplement parts et
à point delta tu es
plus le pendule se déplace vite plus le
vecteur er tourner rapidement
et ceci dans cette direction cette
direction si qui la direction
perpendiculaire à faire c'est à dire la
direction et état
donc ici on peut écrire que la variation
de er par rapport au temps la dérive et
est donné par tête à poindre le tda
de façon assez similaire si le pendule
cette fois ci si on regarde le vecteur
est état
si le pendule tourne à l'instant suivant
le vecteur ce sera également aurait
également tourné d'un certain angle
c'est d'ailleurs le même angle delta
teta
qu'on note tête à point delta t
et cette fois ci ce vecteur cette
rotation se fait dans ce sens là c'est à
dire suivant la direction - 1er puisque
ce vecteur ci est le vecteur er donc
cette fois ci c'est suivant - 1er et
donc on à la dérive et 2e d'état par
rapport au temps qui est moins teta
points 1 er
bon eh bien maintenant qu'on a ces deux
expressions on va pouvoir calculer la
dérivée du vecteur v par rapport au
temps donc la dérivée du vecteur v par
rapport au temps c'est simplement
l'accélération la dérivée de la vitesse
et l'accélération donc c'est la dérive
et de l est et a point eu d'état donc on
va dériver chaque terme le elle ici est
une constante dont on n'a pas besoin de
le dérivé on doit dérivés ici le produit
de teta points et eux d'état alors la
dérivée d'un produit c'est la dérive et
de teta point fois peu et a plus d'êta
point fois la dérive et de l'état donc
on a des tas points points c'est à dire
la dérivée seconde de teta par rapport
au temps x e et a plus l etat point
fois la dérive et deux états par rapport
au temps et on l'a calculé ici c'est
moins d'état points 1 er
et donc l'accélération du pendule le
vecteur accélération est donnée par l
etat points pointent dans la direction
et état - l etat poincaré dans la
direction de m
et cette expression ici est d'ailleurs
valable quelle que soit la situation dès
qu'on a des coordonnées polaires comme
ça autour d'un point
c'est l'expression de l'accélération on
reconnaît ici l'accélération centrifuge
est ici l'accélération qui est due à la
variation de teta au cours du temps
donc cette expression de l'accélération
ici est purement cinématiques pour
l'instant on n'a mis aucune physique
dans notre problème en particulier la
gravité ici la force de gravité ne
compte pas
donc l'étape suivante ça va être de
déterminer l'accélération cette fois ci
à partir du principe fondamental de la
dynamique c'est-à-dire avec le bilan des
forces qui s'appliquent sur la masse
pour comparer les deux expressions qu'on
obtient alors faisons un bilan des
forces
ici on a dit que le pendule ne subit que
la gravité en réalité la masse subit
également une force diriger le long de
la tige qui la maintient à une distance
constante du pivot c'est la force de
tension de la tige donc si on note t
l'intensité de cette force alors la
force du poids est donné par mg le poids
cm x l'accélération de la pesanteur et
donc la somme des forces qui
s'appliquent sur la masse
en vecteur
c'est le poids mg
donc j'ai ici c'est un vecteur diriger
vers le bas que je vais noter comme ça
plus la tension tht et
alors la tension est dirigée suivants -
1er vers l'intérieur donc on peut écrire
que la tension s'était sa norme x - er
est par contre pour mg il faut faire
attention donc m j'ai ici le vecteur en
question c'est le vecteur unité dirigée
vers le bas ce vecteur on peut
l'exprimer par rapport à 1 er et 2 e
état et on voit que si la gravité est
dirigée vers le bas
l'angle ici entre er
et le vecteur j'ai cet angle c'est
l'angle l'état justement c'est
l'inclinaison du pendule
est donc en projetant ici le vecteur g /
er et sur deux états avec un peu de
trigonométrie on n'obtient que j'ai est
égal à sa norme fois le cosinus de teta
x er et si on voit que ça c'est le sinus
de teta ici
- le sinus de teta fois à deux états
puisqu'ici cette longueur c'est le sinus
de teta
avec un signe - puisque c'est dans
l'autre sens par rapport à août et a
donc ici je vais décalé ça pour avoir la
place et on peut écrire que la force de
gravité s'applique suivant cost et à 1
er - sin tétas le tda
on a désormais le bilan des forces qui
s'appliquent sur la masse on va pouvoir
utiliser l'équation f
alors sommes des forces plutôt égal m à
l'expression du principe fondamental de
la dynamique pour déterminer
l'accélération de la masse à partir des
forces alors f égale m a donc à égal f /
n est donc l'accélération
c'est toute cette expression / m donc en
particulier on a alors on va regrouper
les termes suivants 1er et peu et a donc
suivant 1er ont nagé cost et à
moin té sur m
le tout suivant 1er - j'ai sinus et à
peut-être
donc ça c'est une autre expression de
l'accélération
alors évidemment le vecteur a ici c'est
le même vecteur dans ces deux
expressions les deux doivent être égaux
mais on les a obtenues de façon
différente celui ci de façon
cinématiques celui ci de façon dynamique
de façon physique à partir des forces
qui s'appliquent sur la masse
et donc on peut dire que ces deux
lecteurs doivent être égaux et en
particulier leurs composantes suivantes
état doit être la même
si bien qu'on peut finalement écrire une
équation qui est que l tête à point
point est égal à moins j'ai signé cet
état
ou en réarrangeant t d'appoint points
égal
1 g / l signe cet état et cette équation
c'est l'équation d'un pendule qui n'est
soumis qu'à la gravitation
donc cette équation nous donne
l'accélération la dérivée seconde de la
fonction teta par rapport au temps en
fonction de tes ta
petite parenthèse on pourrait également
dire que ces deux termes doivent eux
aussi être égaux
mais cette égalité ne nous servirait pas
vraiment puisque on ne connaît pas la
valeur de la tension tht est donc en
fait cette égalité ne servirait qu'à
déterminer la valeur de la tension
bon et bien maintenant on a obtenu
l'équation de la dynamique du pendule au
cours du temps et on aimerait bien
résoudre cette équation pour trouver la
fonction teta de thé la fonction qui
donne la position du pendule au cours du
temps
alors malheureusement cette équation ici
ne peut pas être résolu de façon
analytique on ne peut pas trouver des
fonctions usuelles qui résolvent cette
équation est donc on va devoir faire une
approximation
l'approximation qu'on fait généralement
c'est de considérer que notre pendule
n'oscille que très peu avec une toute
petite amplitude et donc en particulier
que le pendule reste près de l'axé
vertical et qu'il ne va pas se balader
vers des angles plus haut
donc on appelle ça l'approximation des
petits angles
dans cette situation l'angle l'état est
donc très petit par rapport à py par
exemple l'anglais était très proche de
zéro et donc on peut émettre
l'approximation que le sinus de teta est
à peu près égale at état lors pourquoi
on peut faire cette approximation si
vous vous souvenez du graff de la
fonction sinus d'état et bien elle a une
forme un peu comme ceux ci
alors ici on a des tas ici on a le sinus
de teta ici c'était à égal 0 ici c'était
à gals pis et si c'était à égal de pie
et donc c'est une fonction qui oscille
comme ça et on voit que très près de
l'origine
le signe cet état est à peu près une
droite de pente 1 c'est à dire que si
notre état est à peu près égale at état
lorsque l'état est proche de zéro une
autre façon de le voir c'est de se
rappeler de la définition géométrique du
sinus donc si on a un triangle rectangle
le sinus c'est ici
l'angle ici cet état ça c'est pour un
cercle trigonométriques donc dip au
tennis un pour un triangle l'hypoténuse
1 et si l'angle est très resserré eh
bien on voit que le sinus ici est à peu
près égale à la longueur de l'arc de
cercle qui est ici donc en fait si on
imagine un triangle rectangle sept
longueurs ici est plus petit que 1 mais
on peut imaginer donc l' arc de cercle
qui complète le cercle trigonométriques
et la longueur de cet arc de cercle et
s'y est donné par l'angle et à ton
disque sept longueurs ici est donné par
le sinus deux états et donc dans
l'approximation ou l'anglais très faible
les deux sont à peu près égaux et donc
si cet état est à peu près égale à tête
a
donc dans cette approximation des petits
angles on avait l'équation teta points
points égal - g / l si cet état donc
ceci est à peu près égale à - g / l etat
à partir de là on a une équation de la
forme t'es tu apprends points égale une
constante négative ici c'est moins g / l
x teta et cette équation on peut la
résoudre c'est l'équation d'un
oscillateur harmonique ou d'un pendule
dans l'approximation des petits angles
et la résolution de cette équation donne
comme solution teta égale une certaine
amplitude une constante à foix le
cosinus de la racine carrée et de j sur
l fois le tenter - t0 une certaine
constante arbitraire qui correspond au
temps auquel le pendule est au maximum
de son amplitude
donc on a une amplitude a ici qui est un
angle
et le pendule va osciller
selon une fonction sinusoïdale entre un
angle à et un angle moins arr